hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be covering from the round
for day two of the Super Beta United
rapid and Blitz tournament currently
being played in Croatia this is the
rapid part and it's also the first game
that finished it actually finished uh
really quickly uh Fabi spent pretty much
no time Magnus spent a bit more but for
a very good reason and you will very
soon see why that is so and now it's
very very uncommon for for magnets to
make such a I don't know if it's it
would be classified as a mistake because
they change these things sometimes you
know what was uh once a blunder is now a
mistake what was a mistake is now an
inaccuracy so you know I don't know the
the precise terminology but uh it's not
the best move yeah so let's check it out
Magnus had the white pieces and he opens
with C4 he goes for the English opening
Knight to F6 with Knight the C3 and the
e5x5 the two knights of the English and
of course you all know what that means
we will have the Four Knights of the
English Knight F3 Knight the C6 and now
striking in the center with the 4 we
have e-captress on the four by Fabi
Knight captures and now Bishop to B4 and
here uh Bishop the G5 is the most common
move Knight captures on C6 is um second
most popular Magnus goes for G3 and now
uh well there are moves that have been
played in this position Fabi plays
Knight to A5 and there is only one move
that uh one game where this move was
played uh by a gentleman named Sergey
rublevsky I did not find it in the
database I just saw an hs24 published it
on on Twitter but as I don't have any
other references to this game I will
call it that it is as of move 6 then we
have a completely new game so let's see
how Magnus deals with this point is that
uh now if you play something like E3 uh
you will get a messed up one structure
here black will play B6 we can get to
the bishop and this will be a permanent
weakness something with the Knight and
a5s similar to like it would have in the
names of Indian defense so Magnus
instead goes Queen to D3 defends the
Knight with the queen and now Pawn the
D5 and okay Magnus trades with a pawn
captors Queen captures the Knight is of
course pin so the queen is safe on D5
and now Queen to B5 with check uh Magnus
forces a queen trade with Bishop D7
Queen characters and Knight captures now
Fabi threatening to win material here
with a captain C3 and Magnus just plays
Bishop to D2 and now Fabi plays Knight
captures on C3 and here you should just
capture the Knight you should play B
captors or Bishop captures but Magnus
decided uh that he didn't want to mess
up his Pawn structure he wanted to kick
away the bishop and then just play
Bishop captures on C3 and have his
Bishop on this long diagonal however
this does not work he played Knight to
C2 but now Fabi said all right obviously
if I go back now you play now you
recapture and now your Bishop is very
strong and white should definitely be
better here however Fabi said alright
but what about Knight captures on A2 now
I've grabbed the pawn I'm already up a
piece and my Bishop here is defended so
Magnus doesn't really have a good option
here he has to play Knight captures on
B4 he could play Bishop captures on B4
but at least for the price of that one
Pawn uh you will have the bishop pair it
is sometimes can be a compensation in
itself Knight captures on B4 and now
Rook captures an A5 Knight the C2 with
check messing up with magnus's King a
little bit King D1 and Knight to D4 and
okay now Magnus has to continue but
still it's The Bishop's pair uh you you
probably will not lose this being done
upon so he plays Pawn to F3 getting
ready to grab the full center with Pawn
to E4 and now Bishop to E6 we have
Bishop to C3 and now Pawn to B6
uh the idea is of course that if you
play Bishop captures uh on D4 then The
Rook will be captured uh but this isn't
even that bad and it might even be the
best move that Magnus has you should
probably give up the exchange here for
the G7 pawn and now okay it's uh Five
Pawns each but at least you've messed up
5V spawn structure a little bit and
still the bishop pair uh can um from
time to time hold such positions but
instead after B6 Magnus did not play
this he did not bring the Rook back he
wanted to have an active Rook he played
Rook to G5 and now Fabi just castles
Queen side we have King to E1 preparing
to shift the king over to F2 G6 by
playing G6 Fabi sets a most deadly trap
but Magnus misses it he just plays King
to F2 and now fabi's position is
completely winning I'm sure you guys can
spot the move but feel free to pause the
video and try to punish the second
inaccuracy or a mistake or a blunder by
Magnus uh while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh always looking
for that weirdest move and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is of course spawn to F6 Ponte F6 and
The Rook is trapped The Rook has no
squares covered by the bishop covered by
the pawn covered by the Knight covered
by the pawn uh no Square unfortunately
for the rook and I I think Magnus
already uh gave up here
um he didn't resigned he just gave up of
course in his mind he probably gave up
maybe even after that the a pawn was
blundered but maybe not maybe he still
thought okay the bishop pair will will
hold their own against uh the extra Pawn
but here E3 uh is the move that should
be played you give up a rook you pick up
the Knight here you attack the rook and
when The Rook gets into the game you
develop Bishop to A6 with the check you
bring the Rook into the game and you
still try to fight and this is the the
max that we're used to seeing you know
even if you're down even it doesn't
matter remember that time that Magnus I
think it was maybe
maybe even 2017 uh I think it was the
Isle of Men Tournament that he was
playing against Wayne Jones and Magnus
blunder the full piece and ended up
winning the game because he or
constantly played the uh the absolute
best move but okay here your opponent is
Fabiano Cortana so chances are even if
you play the absolute best move you will
not be beating him uh but yeah it's
probably something that uh you know
we're accustomed to seeing from Magnus
but he played Rook to G4 and now uh Fabi
just uh takes the takes the exchange
messes up his Pawn structure and goes
Rook H to E8 with full development and
now not only is Magnus uh done the
exchange but also his Pawn structure is
all messed up so he plays Spawn H4 we
have Pawn to C5 and now Ponte H5 fabul
blocks the position we have Pawn to H6
Knights to B5 now preparing to capture
the bishop with Bishop back T1 and now
Rook to D1 Fabi with uh full activity
all over the board we have E3 and now
nice to D6 now the Knight is coming to
E4 with k into F3 and King to C7 we have
Bishop D2 Chasing The Rook away but just
the Rook to B1 now the problem with
Bishop to D3 attacking the rook and the
H7 pawn and it seems that Magnus will
eliminate the H7 pawn and create a
passer here uh but uh it is far too late
for such things a bishop captures on H7
was played now comes Knight to C4 and he
was in this position on move 31 that
Magnus Carlsen resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
really there isn't even though okay you
could move the Bushman start pushing
that pawn there's just uh
a normal that you can do d three point
is hanging you have to defend it somehow
let's say you play Bishop to F2 uh no 95
check you know what do you what do you
do if King to G4 if King G2 you just
play Knight captures and G4 now again
the bishop is lost if you try to defend
it then Knight captures an E3 with check
the bishop his spin so you're gonna lose
the Rook as well King G1 Knight captures
King captures and okay you might argue
yes it's a bishop we still have the
bishop pair uh maybe the pass Pawn can
do something but just rook h8 and that's
it once the bishop moves you're gonna
pick up the the the past pawn and that
is it so unfortunately for Magnus no
coming back from this it was uh you know
an inaccuracy that led to a mistake that
led to a blunder uh and that's uh well
well either of those is enough for Fabi
to win the game against anyone but all
three that's just not gonna do so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
very nicely done by Fabi he now
overtakes Magnus in the first place but
it all depends on how other games finish
as this is the first game that finished
and how the leader vishwanathan and will
also conduct his game so we'll check up
on that as well I would like to thank
James Eugene Cashman John Austin notkin
plays Bullet just thriller.com and uh
Paul Miller for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here and thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful tournament until it finishes
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day